this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode we're back with
bungie's sci-fi shooter as jonathan
takes a look at some of the exotic
weaponry from destiny 2 which only
slightly melted his brain wow this is
truly exotic i know just a completely
bonkers design has to be said
if you're a fan of destiny make sure to
check our previous two episodes on the
game's guns and for something slightly
different keep your eye on game spot for
an upcoming video with ex-sas member
billy billingham as he reacts to various
sas missions from the call of duty
franchise you know having been part of
some of this stuff that that to me felt
really good really really realistic and
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below right let's get
back to destiny
right so this is this is called the
arbolest which is a real historical term
for one of a number of um arrow shooting
weapons basically this obviously doesn't
shoot arrows per se quite a messy
looking design quite a lot of pipes and
tubes and things on it this it's got a
reflex type site positioned in front of
the eye
fine looks a bit fragile in fact the
whole weapon looks quite fragile so that
sight would whatever it's made of would
be very easy to knock out of tr of zero
with the barrel or whatever this is and
break the glass if it is glass it might
not be the various pipes and tubes that
could be easily dented
ripped off so it has the almost the area
of prototype the way it's stocked i
suppose is reminiscent of as the name
would imply some sort of crossbow type
weapon but it doesn't have the the prod
of a crossbow
or the arms of a compound bow but it's
clearly meant to evoke some sort of a
bow without having a
literal bow of course where the name
comes from do we have anything like that
now not really but there's something
called an air bow which is halfway
between
effectively an arrow
shooting weapon a bow
and a gun because it's stopped more like
a gun but it does have some sort of
residual
modern crossbow looking heritage to the
design and i think that's what they're
going for here
all right this is a surprising looking
weapon the the ward cliff coil this is
obviously some in-game law reference
very unusual looking thing i have no
idea what it's supposed to be but it
tells me it says it fires a volley of
rockets so i guess those okay i can sort
of see where they're coming from here so
if you look at the rocket pods on
something like a hind gun ship they have
all the multiple holes in the front for
the rockets to get shot out of it's kind
of reminiscent of that but the way the
holes are rendered is kind of boggling
my mind because they seem to be
orientated incorrectly for how the
things would shoot out but i haven't
seen it yet let's have a look
i might have misunderstood what they
were going for with the the holes in the
globular front end of this thing not
quite clear on where the warheads emerge
from anyway but um given it has
interchangeable front ends that don't
necessarily even have those holes i
think they're just meant to be cooling
or something and the warheads must come
out of the big hole big old hole in the
front and the other thing is it's just
it does not look like a portable weapon
clearly it is but um it looks like a
mounted it's more like a concept for a
sentry gun to me i guess the the
characters are effectively augmented so
it doesn't really matter but it's
certainly it fits a bit of a prototype
because you know someone has lashed this
up and you're having to just awkwardly
cart it around the battlefield
[Music]
this is a good reminder that we are
playing essentially if i'm watching a
fantasy game vaguely set in space it's
not real it's not really science fiction
that may be controversial i don't know
but that that's my strong impression
from a gun made of rats well sort of
elaborately carved like is it meant to
be stone it looks like stone uh with
depictions of rats and then there's an
actual rat skull or it might be a bit
big for that melded into the back of it
somehow we've got some detail though
because the as well as the texturing of
the decoration we've got a visible
rifling very small but deep grooves you
see this on some early rifles and muzzle
loading rifles tend to have a lot of
grooves with a slow rate of twist some
vague conventional looking features in
the the trigger guard trigger area is
vaguely 1911 looking but it's this is
just so wacky this is essentially a
magical legendary type weapon i think
looking at the traits as well where we
apparently we've got a magnified effect
when others are using it the idea of a
swarm of rats i guess a bit meta for for
a shooter but there we go
all right so we've got this we've got
this thing in action now the the the
eyes on the skull glow red it's got
quite a lot of recoil the slide it is a
slide it does move there's no ejection
port or anything and no ejection so we
can assume that this is some form
probably magical caseless ammunition the
problem with that is how do you
clear like if your magic fails you and
the round doesn't fire how do you get it
out of the chamber does it even have a
chamber it must do it has a rifled
barrel bit of a mystery this one
all right so all of these are so far
living up to their name as exotics this
is looking a bit more conventional maybe
some sort of self-loading pistol or
maybe an automatic as in fully automatic
pistol with an under-barrel launcher of
some kind
[Music]
okay so this
all of these exotic things are going to
blow my my brain i think although it
appears to be like a conventional pistol
with some sort of launcher underneath
what i think is happening is the top
part of the gun is actually like a
charging system for the under barrel bit
that actually projects the beam of
energy that gives you the more powerful
shot how that relates to the normal
barrel shooting normal energy bullets i
don't know
this looks a bit more like what i would
expect an exotic weapon in a game like
destiny to look like with the
the monstrous animalistic in this case
mouth around it i think i might have
said this before and still can't show
you them but we have some 16th century
guns and loose barrels in the collection
where the rest of the gun has been lost
but the beautifully um decorated barrel
still exists and and also in some
southeast asian gun designs as well
where
there's a dragon or a lion or something
at the muzzle so it's like it's
breathing fire or the idea of power like
harnessing the
spirit of an animal almost so that's
something we do see on real guns not
really anymore otherwise this is like a
i don't know an hk 69 type handheld
grenade launcher so let's have a look
it has a vaguely grenade launcher style
sight but it's not clear how that would
function and it's not functional in the
game either the design is pretty cool
with the the the helical flutes
along the barrel and the sort of animal
designs and the the gameplay aspect of
the grenade so we see we have different
grenades going on some are sort of
bursting in mid-air clearly though it's
possible for them to bounce which is
very reminiscent of the original quake 1
grenade launcher so grenades that bounce
around the battlefield are not a great
idea but there is of course a type of
grenade that you do have to use in this
way and that's tear gas cs gas that kind
of thing where you cannot have it
explode you need to get it into a space
for it to then
function and fill the room full of
gas so they do bounce and users of those
will potentially bounce them off things
not not to the extent of this ideally
you'll just want to want it to land in
the middle of the room shoot it through
a window or something ideally you don't
want to be bouncing it off surfaces but
it kind of happens by default um and
they say some skilled people have used
it to their advantage
all right bad juju i like that name that
is funny
and it's clearly got well it's got bones
on it i can say that much quite an
advanced sci-fi looking design
contrasting with the random crow skull
or something and some vertebrae on the
back
some random straps with horns on which
does make it look a bit like it's trying
to dress up for a halloween party with
some horns a bit strange and we have an
effect here that it clearly seems to
derive from the bones of basically
in-game curses which is interesting
kills refill the magazine that's one
aspect um you get increased damage let's
see if we can see that in action
you have advantage
all right some function functional sites
here albeit they're a little wacky
basically a red dot but we have sort of
bars coming in from the side that glow
green the whole gun glows green because
it's you know delivering curses
effectively no problem with that i
suppose in a way this sort of sums up at
least the exotic weapons in in destiny
in that it's quite a high-tech looking
assault rifle basically with these weird
supernatural elements that all that that
appear to be added to it so someone has
magicked up a sort of off-the-shelf
sci-fi gun which is quite a quite cool
idea
wow this is truly exotic looking very
strange we've got futuristic looking
technological lower parts with very
unergonomic looking pistol grip strange
butt stock and a very conventional
looking scope above and then a very odd
looking barrel this this this has to be
a magical weapon but it's it's kind of
maybe
the idea is it's a magical pointy stabby
type weapon that someone has adapted
using technology into a rifle if that
makes sense or something maybe like a
staff that projects energy and someone
has converted it into a rifle that's
that's the impression i'm getting from
this the way it has no it has no bore it
has a pointy end almost gizelle looking
up curved stock except it's not really a
stock until someone has added a metal
stock around that so you can actually
shoulder it quite an intriguing concept
but having said all that there is a
magazine housing and what looks to be a
magazine underneath so
i think i might be on the right lines
with this it really does look like some
magical artifact adapted as a sniper
rifle why on earth you would need to
change magazines and cycle the action i
mean what action i don't know kind of
like the way they've designed in these
clamps to secure the
barrel that isn't really a barrel um but
if this is some sort of i don't know
maybe it's taken off a creature or
something it has its own power supply
and therefore you need to adapt a human
power supply to keep it charged don't
know i'm sure the comments will
enlighten me
okay i think this is the first of these
exotic guns i've seen that sort of makes
some sense in terms of the
feed belt of cartridges of some kind in
a belt box effectively attached to the
side of the gun or the lift up top cover
similar to what we have today in fact
they've modeled the
feed arm that would sit underneath in
the underside of the top cover and be
driven back and forth as the gun
operates but i it wouldn't doesn't
appear to have a it's not actually
hinged it doesn't move so it's a just a
bit of decoration really but it helps
cement the idea that this is like a belt
fed machine gun although the
configuration of the front end and the
big cable running to the front and the
spinny bit in the middle all makes me
think this is actually some kind of a
rail gun it doesn't have a barrel it has
parallel rails and it seems to be
accelerating the projectiles i think
yeah watching this thing actually shoot
it's more akin to a grenade machine gun
or an automatic grenade launcher very
slow rate of fire big chunky projectiles
the the chinese drum fed
type of portable grenade launcher so not
the belt but that has a drum
it's an interesting thing i'm not sure
what's going on on the top what that
sort of weird looking ribbed thing is on
top don't know what that does we've got
a sort of very tall holographic-esque
sight i'm not sure how that works but it
does have a sight and it's not they're
not redundant iron sights which is a
common thing on less realistic
games
right instant points for having a
holographic projection without a frame
as the optical sight as those of you who
watch this before will know i'm a big
fan of that idea that it will
essentially just appear in mid-air
through some sort of emitter and it
won't require a protective frame or any
kind of glass or perspex or anything
like that the alternative futuristic gun
sight will be one that is projected in
front of your eyes the reticle's kind of
a bit overly complex like why would you
need holographic blue stuff that
obscures your field of view when you
could literally just have a cross hair
or a reticle dot and donut thing just
hovering in midair
my um
ramblings about the site have been
somewhat undermined by the fact that
this clearly has a the ammunition
counter which floats below the reticle
is also linked to it so your actual
outer reticle turns red or changes color
when you're running out of ammunition
that's something i could see being
useful i'm not sure that it would be
adopted we still don't have round
counters really in contemporary
military time weapons
right interesting looking revolver here
we've got the faceted cylinder of and
the
lower barrel as it were of a of the
chiappa rhino but the rest of it's quite
different very notably there's um what
looks a lot like a kitchen knife
built into the gun below a lot of the
blade is actually behind the muzzle so
you can't use it for stabbing you could
though use it as a cutting weapon
using that cutting edge so having it set
back that far is not necessarily the end
of the world but does compromise its
effectiveness as a bayonet the spiky
studs all over it
what can i say it definitely hurt if you
slap someone in the face with this thing
but they are clearly there for aesthetic
reasons as is all of that what looks
like applied decoration in this case
it's in sort of what looks like silver
or platinum and then with gold edging as
well oh we do have a sort of
ivory-esque grip on there as well just
to just to top it off
as with some other games with advanced
looking sci-fi type revolvers it's not
clear how this functions it does have a
hammer it's kind of semi-concealed or
semi-guarded behind some weird prong
things that stick out the back i don't
really know what why they're there if
the hammer is not functional there's no
ability to [ __ ] it back for a more
accurate shot which they might be
haven't seen it yet i'm not sure why it
even has a hammer other than for visual
reasons but it's firing at quite a rate
i don't know if it's meant to be like an
auto revolver in some way instead of
loading cartridges into the cylinder in
traditional fashion there's an insert
containing the rounds that you can just
drop out so it's a it's a magazine fed
revolver let's call it an on block clip
for a revolver which is very strange not
great because you're creating a lot of
bulk in the cylinder that doesn't need
to be there i think that's the reason
that no one has done that um also the
the outer cylinder housing is visibly
revolving so somehow that clip insert
thing has to engage with that to then
revolve with it but there isn't any
mechanical means of that happening so
that would just kind of spin out of
alignment and you'd end up with a bullet
striking the forcing cone of the
revolver yeah i need to
unthink this
okay this is quite striking the graviton
lance appears to have um like a pocket
universe contained within it there's a
void at the back that has some stars and
galaxies visible in it and there's like
a tube running from that all the way
around doubling back on itself
under the barrel doesn't really make a
lick of sense but it's something very
different and quite cool it's another
bullpup it's got some kind of power
supply where the magazine would go
another rather uncomfortable looking
pistol grip but hey different species
have different hands and then the barrel
looks more like a pair of rails for
accelerating a projectile but that
doesn't look like that's how this works
so it's more just like an emitter for as
the description says space time although
it does say the weapon this weapon is
the needle i don't think it's referring
to any kind of projectile it's a
metaphor
i suppose my fear with having seen this
was that it you know implies that it's
harnessing the energy of space-time to
be a weapon and my fear was that it
would then be quite anemic and not do
much damage but actually a couple of
shots from the conventional
mode seems to kill things pretty pretty
readily and then there's this black hole
effect where the enemies kind of implode
and then there's an explosion it does
kind of meet expectations i think as a
universe harnessing weapon
another bayonet source edged weapon
on a on a gun this one looks quite
potent albeit it's extremely big and
thick in cross-section with a sort of
triangular cross-section making it
extremely heavy and extremely front
heavy as well given that the gun will
weigh potentially less than the edge
weapon it's not quite a gun blade but
it's um knocking on the door of it quite
quite a distinctive design the way that
the receiver tapers into a butt stock
with the sort of two voids in it quite
an interesting design
right so unlike the pulse rifles
logically enough are energy weapons the
auto rifles are firing something like
conventional ammunition the cartridge
cases are a really weird shape there
must be some sort of chamber that works
with those but they wouldn't work well
in a
conventional firearm chamber that's for
sure they're very thin at the back thick
in the middle and thin again at the
other end and there is appears to be a
rim as well so the rim isn't any wider
than the maximum diameter of the case
there's a reason why we use rimless
ammunition where the the rim is created
by cutting a groove into the into the
head so it's the same the same diameter
so that it can feed through an automatic
weapon this looks problematic
wow this is truly exotic the name is
intriguing osteo striga
i'm not 100 sure on the language but um
sounds a lot like bone witch if anyone
knows the precise language put it in the
comments but uh yeah it does look quite
bony and quite sort of cursed so maybe
there's some witchcraft involved ah yes
sentient toxic projectiles that track
the targeted enemy ah sounds familiar
more so than the other guns that i've
seen changing the skin changes the
complete design like the the black
looking
skin for this weapon or alternate
version of it has a conventional barrel
more bony looking one with a sort of
jade shard as a barrel doesn't really
have a barrel so it's changed up quite
drastically while still being the same
gun
all right this is a very novel idea gun
sensibilities but a completely magical
weapon okay still a gun and it's
launching projectiles but it's not a gun
in this in the literal sense because it
doesn't have a barrel a gun has to have
a barrel and also the magazine magazine
is
some sort of magical artifact that sits
on the top of the gun a bit like a p90
but you don't have to take it off again
because it erodes or decays
as it's using up the sort of magical
ammunition that it contains very
inventive got to give them that i
suppose it's no different really than
like a magic sword in a fantasy game
guns are destiny's thing so this is what
they've done i know just a completely
bonkers design has to be said
okay that's us done those are the guns
or the exotics of destiny i am of course
here at the royal armouries as always in
leeds but um we do have other sites
sadly not in other countries love to
have as many people as possible visit we
also have our digital presence as well
as my appearance on here uh we have a
youtube channel and all the usual social
media channels as well so do check those
out thanks very much for watching see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you